hey what's up guys my name is eternal
welcome to episode 25 of game
programming so yesterday we do look at
the basic overview of the level class
and today we're going to take help take
a look at the overview of the random
generation of a level this is again
going to be a very simple random
generation just to give you guys an idea
again there are lot of people out there
who have no idea how random generation
even works we're not going to talk about
stuff like noise mapping right now okay
that's just as very advanced random
generation that we might actually cover
in the future but certainly not now but
just a basic overview of how random
generation is going to work so at the
moment we've set up this little public
level thing which is basically like a
random generation constructor right
because this is the constructor where we
actually load a level from a file this
is the constructor in which we actually
generate a random level so you can see
what it does is it is it actually
specified init inputs these variables as
the width and height of how big we
actually want the random a randomly
generated level and then of course it
sets this int here called tiles as
integer this our array of integers
called tiles equal to a new int to the
amount of index it basically sets the
size of the array to the size of the map
therefore setting this array to contain
and one index or one one integer for
every tile on the map and that integer
is going to specify what type of tile it
is so if we go around here into our
private void generate level what we're
actually going to talk about is how
random generation will work and again
what we could do in fact what we will do
right now is actually make a new class
called random would level alright and
random level is going to extend level
alright what that means is that suddenly
it's it's extending it right it's
inheriting all this and I'll show you
guys how that roughly works in just a
minute first of all we see straight away
that we explore extending level and we
actually get an error right our error
over here is that implicit girls show up
here actually
that there's a super constructor for it
I it's under fight so there's no no
default constructor if we actually go in
here and simply put public level which
is the default constructor you'll see
this error goes away but because we
don't have a default constructor you can
see that here we've actually got
parameters we actually need to use one
of these constructors over here
so obviously the constructor that I'm
going to use here is the int int one
right I want to use this one because
this is the actual one if we go into
here we see the one with int width and
in height is the one that actually
generates our level so we've we've
called that up now right so it runs what
this does again what super means is that
whatever whatever parameters we input
here is basically going to input back
into here into these two and run this
constructor okay so the word super
refers to the extending constructor to
the super classes constructor and it
will again execute all the code that is
in that constructor so we see the
generate level is there now if we come
in here and we type private void
generate level right you'll see that
first of all this is a completely
different method right because it's it's
it's extending it right because sorry
because I'm because it's private now if
we set this to protected and likewise
this to protected you'll see the
suddenly Eclipse gives us this little
green arrow which has it overrides the
level general level method right what
this means is whatever code we actually
put in here it will actually execute
when we run this method right so it
overrides it so in other words if this
method is run and the type that we
specified to be is random level then
whatever is here will run so this is
we're actually going to put up all that
code which actually generates our random
level if we actually come in here you
saw that everything is private we'll
just set that equal to protect
so everyone set it equal to protector
we'll change it to protected I can spell
Pro tech head and tiles as well all
right
originally I made a private because I
was going to actually do all of it and
here but I thought you know what I'm
just going to make different classes for
this because it's more organized that
way and so what we can do here in this
protected word generate level is say
that for in I sorry for in y equals 0 Y
is actually less than the amount of
tiles from the height so in other words
Y is less in height y plus plus and
again a nested for-loops inside that for
in x equals 0 X is less than width so X
let's now level with X plus plus right
well actually going to set we're
actually going to make a new um random
object here so private random random
people's new random and we'll actually
make it final as well and again we can
import that and what the random class
allows us to do is randomly generate
numbers or boolean's alright so in other
words we want to randomly generate a
number because what what we're doing
here right is we've got an array of
integers called tiles and in that array
what's happening in that array is it
obviously it contains numbers that's
what it contains integers that's what it
contains
so each integer is actually going to be
an ID for a tile so in other words ID 0
might be grass ID 1 might be a stone 2
might be wood and 3 for example might be
I don't know water ok so over here we
actually need to fill this tile array
with values of course because at the
moment it doesn't have a value to it so
what that means is that it's empty it's
got its it's empty
we actually need to give it values I
think the default value there will be 0
because that's about that's default
value of an integer but we obviously
want to randomly fill it with with tiles
the way we do that is again this this
these four loops
exist to cycle through every index in
that tiles ensuring that we actually
fill it completely and what we're going
to do here is simply put tiles X plus y
times width and you you've seen this
before you remember how that works
hopefully if not you can rewatch a
previous episode because I explained
that equals random dot next int and now
this parameter here is is how many
numbers we want to generate actually no
I shouldn't I shouldn't say like that
it's the range of numbers that we want
to generate so if we put four here it's
going to generate some out of four
numbers so it's either going to give us
0 1 2 or 3
all right 0 1 2 & 3 that's 4 values it's
going to give us 4 different up to 4
different values if we leave it blank
it's just gonna give us freaking any
number pretty much and if we put in
something like I don't know 8 for
example it's going to give us a random
number anywhere from 0 to 7 all right so
it's 0 to 4 0 to 3 sorry
will be will be good and what this code
again is going to do is is kind of it's
actually going to just give it a random
number so therefore a random I'd a
random tile ID and that is therefore
going to you know place the random tiles
somewhere in the level now you might be
thinking why on earth would you put this
in two for loops instead of actually
doing something like that because again
this would also work if I did something
like tiles dot length and then again
pretty much copied this code here and
replace this with high that would
actually probably give you the same
result now the reason I did this way is
because when we actually get into some
more advanced our tile generations come
and random generations we want to be
able to control specific tiles not just
all in one go all right so for example I
might want to say that the tile at
coordinate 10 x + 8 y
might be water wishes through for
example all right that sort of way I
want to be able to control this way but
yeah anyway that's how random generation
is going to work next time we're
probably going to go into actually
rendering it into rendering you know
this random level that we've created
here are and correctly calling it of
course correctly instantiated and
actually generating this level arm as
well as you know rendering to the screen
mode making a few more tiles in
paint.net they're ready to go but um
yeah I hope you enjoyed this episode of
3d game bro not 3d game printer in my
bad I hope you enjoyed this episode of
game programming
speaking of 3d game programming that
will be back shortly alright I'll be
back soon as I have time actually work
on something bigger and now as well so
I'm kind of busy
but 3d game programming will be back
game programming though I hope you
enjoyed this episode if you did please
hit the like button and I'll see you
guys tomorrow bye guys bye
you